should I say hi I don't want to interact
no one's paying attention I don't need
to say anything but does that make me
look anti-social please don't sit next
to me
please don't why is having another
person sitting next to me so
uncomfortable I feel like they're too
close not to interact [ __ ] now we just
stand here silently god this is so
awkward to ace
say something I'll just watch the floors
change I'll go later hmm okay just K I
say something wrong maybe she wants to
have lunch later Gary until the tea
video everyone's looking at me my heart
is pounding they can probably tell him
nervous that's so embarrassing taiko for
a handshake a hug
churches wave oh hey do you want to come
out tonight everyone's going uh I think
I'm just gonna go home
when god I am lame they probably hate me
think I'm super antisocial when do I
wave am I too far to wave I think my
palms are sweating hi
it was so great catching up with you
I'll see you later
wow that was nice I really think that
went okay
[Music]
Wow
[Music]